تنضم الينا السيد شرحبيل الغريب الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي سيد الغريب تابعنا قبل
قليل صور تشييع عدد من شهداء الغارات
الاسرائيليه اليوم حشود كبيره غضب كبير
كذلك
وتوعد من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه بالرد
برايك ما طبيعه الرد المرتقب من قبل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه
تحيه لك والساده المشاهدين بدايه في
تقديري
البيان الغرفه المشتركه للفصائل المقامه
الفلسطينيه كان واضحا هناك توعد برد قاسي
وموجع للاحتلال الاسرائيلي على ارتكاب مثل
هذه الجريمه وبالتالي بعد مرور اكثر من
سبع ساعات على عدم رد ميداني من قبل
الفصائل هذا يعني يقرا في سياق التاني
الذي يعني اتخذته المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
سبيل ودراسه تحديد حجم وطبيعه الرد على
هذه الجريمه باغتيال ثلاثه من قيادات
سرايا القدس مع عوائلهم في قطاع غزه فجر
هذا اليوم في تقديري كل السيناريوهات
اليوم بعد هذا البيان اصبحت يعني متوقعه
في تقدير
لا بد من رد اولي على مثل هذه الجريمه
لانه ما جرى بالف هو محاوله اسرائيليه
لفرض معادله واستئناف سياسه الاغتيالات
التي توقفت منذ سنوات طويله وبالتالي يعني
قضيه الرد الاول الحتمي هي قضيه مفروغ
منها ويمكن ان يكون هناك رد وفق قراءه
وليه باسم غرفه العمليات المشتركه بمشاركه
جميع الفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه علينا
ان نتوقف عند تصريح وزير الامن الاسرائيلي
او وزير يؤثنت عفوا عندما يقول بانه
الاراضي المحتله او المناطق حتى 40 كيلو
هي مناطق يعني مضطربه ويجب يعني اخذ كل
احتياطات الامنيه هذا معناه بانه هناك
تقديرات اسرائيليه على الجهه المقابله
التي تنتظر وتترقب ماذا يمكن ان تتصرف
المقاومه الفلسطينيه خلال الساعات القريه
المقبله كيف تتصرف وهذا طبيعه الان هل هل
سيكون الرد نعم سيد
شرحبيل التريز في الرد او عدم رد حتى الان
الا يمكن ان تستغله اسرائيل ربما لمصلحتها
بعمليه استباقيه او احباط اي رد محتمل
هذه افتراضيه يعني متوقعه اذا ما توفر
لاسرائيل والاحتلال الاسرائيلي بنك
معلومات وبنك اهداف ممكن ان يكون هناك
ضربه استباقيه وبالتالي مهم جدا ان تاخذ
الفصائل الفلسطينيه هذا على محمل الجد
بمدى واهميه خطوره المشهد القادم خلال
الساعات القادمه لكن في تقدير حتى اللحظه
من يتابع الشان الاسرائيلي بشكل اساسي
يدرك بانه هناك حاله ترقب وحاله يعني حيره
ما هو الرد القادم ما هو حجمه في تقديري
الرد الاولي سيكون يعني رد واضح وصريح
باسم غرفه العمليات المشتركه هذا الرد من
شانه ان يحدد مسارات الميدان الى اين
ستسيير وستاول الامور خلال الساعات هل
ستقتصر على حدود 40 كيلو متر ام ست يعني
ستنزلق الامور الى اكثر من ذلك هذا يعني
من شان سيحدد الميدان وطبي الرد والرد فعل
الاسرائيلي على الرد المتوقع من قبل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه وبالتالي يبقى المشهد
في حاله ترقب وترقب كبير من اجل تحديد
سيناريوهات الساعات القليل المقبله هل
يعني ستقتصر على يعني رشقات متبادله تبادل
رسائل النار ام سيكون هناك حرب شامله
ومفتوحه لا احد يضمنها في الميدان هذا كله
يعني سيتم
التحديد ومن خلال الساعات القليله المقبله
حول طبيعه رد اسرائيل اعذرني فقط اسرائيل
عولت كثيرا على فصل المساحات الى اي
الساحات الى اي مدى اكد بيان غرفه
العمليات المشتركه بان التوافق قائم
يعني ربما من احد اهم الاهداف الاسرائيليه
من وراء حادثه الاغتيال هذه
لطالما منذ انطلقت صواريخ من جنوب لبنان
ومن سوريا نحن كمراقبين حذرنا من
القياده الاسرائيليه قياده الاحتلال وضعت
قضيه الاغتيالات على الطاوله هناك اهداف
اسرائيليه داخليه وخارجيه من وراء تنفيذ
هذا هذا الاغتيال كان متوقعا ان تستبق
اسرائيل ضربه استباقيه باغتيال احد قيادات
المقاومه لتحقيق هدف ربما اشكرك عذرا
للمقاطعه اشكرك جزيلا الشكر ضيفنا من غزه
شرحبيل الغريبه الكاتب والمحلل السياسي